and so in so the 28,000 that literally
just covers a sense of getting into
canvas you know sure that this doesn't
include it sounds like maybe a little
bit of post maybe not and then all there
but no no distribution not nothing
beyond that mainly just to get the
product complete yeah exactly so our
goal our goal was to get the project
complete you know get get post started
and in the meantime start going through
traditional methods to get the money for
for post and distribution and things
like that and we were going to continue
at the same time to to continue building
an audience since we started online
we're going to stay online we have the
two new episodes we are going to start
an online transmedia element with some
blogs and different websites that link
to different found-footage type of
things and things like that so we're
going to continue audience building
while we made the after we made the
feature and and going traditional
financing methods to cover the the
difference of the rest events and so
let's see if you understand this
correctly now is this what you're
working on here with your anything
morning for is this is this a web series
and 0 and a feature film simultaneously
how did you know so so our original idea
was to do a second season but you know
like he said once we looked at the
script and what we had it was kind of my
idea and I you know on a walk from to
the neighborhood one night I was just
like it's like you have 70 pages that
seems like a real people I was like you
know if you add another 20 pages and a
little bit more was like we can just do
this as a feature and then you don't
have to worry about the you know having
to end each episode in suspense like the
way that the characters had developed it
just it didn't feel right anymore like
it was trying to cram the story that he
had in his head into this format that we
had originally picked but I was like
like what's like what's the reason and
and it sort of started as a
philosophical conversation about like
writing like like so how open are you to
like different genres or different you
know you know just trying to get him cuz
I you know for me it was important for
him to just get that story out and I was
like
like what's the difference like whether
it's a feature or whether it's a film or
whether it's even like a novel or this
and I was just trying to like poke a
little bit and NC and then I think on
the way back when he sort of like I
think that's when we kind of made the
decision we're like no like this this is
a feature this is what we're gonna try
is our first feature like why why wait
why do the season if this is what the
story is telling us to do then well yeah
exactly and Simon and so yeah that's
exactly the Kickstarter is for is for
the feature so we already shot the two
episodes and then any of the transmedia
videos in episodes that we shoot would
come later but the Kickstarter sort of
this webisode you shot the two episodes
we shot what it was that those were to
kind of transition the ohm the tone of
what we did in the first season to what
the feature is going to feel like
because it's a very different tone you
can't reel we couldn't really shoot that
style wouldn't wouldn't feel right as a
feature so we wanted to do something
that felt a little more like that in
these two episodes yeah so big was this
jolting when Violet approaches us say no
but let's sort of scrap the webseries
idea you know and let's let's just crack
this to a feature because you say
something like that but you know
structurally you know there's so many
like sort of the way that the structure
is the bones are you know you start you
start flipping around a little idea is
it's just like that becomes a lot of
work so can you yeah talk about like
Mike was that an easy thing for you to
like embrace I I thought it was gonna be
awesome I was really excited I went home
I was like I just got a tackle on 20
more pages and we're ready to shoot a
feature and then um a couple of painful
nights later is like you know coming out
of an operating room and being like we I
gotta start over I just am the web serie
script is very good friends in a future
script and like you said that the
structure of the bones of it um the
pacing of it um it's all very different
and I couldn't just I could have just
stretch out things here and there at
go back from the beginning take the the
the concept and so he wanted to tell and
completely overhaul it and you tried at
first to write I was trying very hard to
stick a um what a square into a round
hole and it just it wasn't working I'm
gonna started like he was doing that
twice you know because we did that
trying to fit this story into that and
he almost had it there and then I was
like stupider and then you know right up
write a script for a feature and then
trying to like reverse it and undo it
and it's just like yeah it was it was
rough for couple days and and I read all
of his work and so I'm kind of like
redoing it thinking of it in a new way
and you know trying to trying to help
him through it but no I definitely was
not as easy as like he was totally on
board like in spirit and like okay yeah
like we're gonna do it this way and then
once it actually came down to his leg
but he never changed the mind he never
thought like you know let's just stick
to the original idea like once we had
decided on future things we felt right
yeah really so yeah what was it about
that you know because you figure like
it's such a struggle to try to convert
this to a feature why not to scrap that
idea say you know what no it's too much
work to do that why did you stick with
the feature I think it's because of its
because the the story we had I think we
did it as a web series because when Nia
was possible for us to do it on her own
as a web series um but what was so
exciting about it was you know being
able to tell this more cinematic story
being able to you know find a way to
have the resources the crew bring on a
bigger cast and things like that there's
a chance to really tell tell the story
that originally interested us including
it in the first place rather than
settling for something that you know
what would be more feasible issue and I
think she liked when we when we
originally started like it was the
characters that were important to us and
the story that these characters have to
tell and I think you get that from
characters in in a feature you know you
get to let go on their journey for the
hour two hours that you're watching them
you know but I think in the webseries
world you don't always get that luxury
to develop the characters we
you have to your you have to keep your
audience interested in coming back you
know every episode and so every episode
has to end a certain way and I think
what drives it is the plot at that point
and not that you necessarily have to
sacrifice the characters for the plot
but it's a lot harder to tell the story
that you want to tell especially a story
that's so focused on characters if
you're busy doing that and originally
that's what he wanted is to tell the
story about these characters and I think
that's kind of why I pushed him in a
different direction and once he realized
that that yeah that was astir he wanted
to tell too but that's not the story
that he was telling in the in the second
season like he wasn't getting to where
he wanted and I think you know that like
like it wasn't working the way that it
was written and I think it was because
of that where where it it wasn't the
story he wanted to tell I think once I
got over the you know having to change
it to a duck Pete Rose very freeing to
have all this room to play and not be
capped by like this is when the episode
supposed to end I mean obviously that
was like this is where the action be and
where we should be at this point in the
second act and where we should go into
the third act but it was it just it felt
a lot more freeing and then you know
being tied down to these a little mini
episode
you